تنطلق هذه المسيره الاحتجاجيه لوحده
الاسعاف والطوارئ احتجاجا على ما قامت به
قوات الاحتلال مع رجال الاسعاف من قصف
مباشر ومن اعتقال لعدد من المسعفين وتدمير
الكثير من سيارات الاسعاف في هذه المسيره
تسجل اعتراضها واحتجاج على كل هذا السلوك
الاجرامي الذي قامت به قوات الاحتلال بحق
من يكون لديهم الاصل حمايه دوليه وحصانه
دوليه في خلال عملياتهم في الميدان خاصه
ان القانون الدولي نص على عدم اعتراض رجال
الاسعاف لكن الكثير منهم استشهدوا بسبب
قصف قوات الاحتلال بالاضافه الىى الاعتقال
المباشر من قوات الاحتلال على الحواجز او
في داخل
الميدان لقد تعرض العديد
من ضباط الاسعاف للقصف المباشر واننا
نواجه مشاكل جمه منها تعرض سيارات الاسعاف
في كثير من الم مواقع للاستهداف المباشر
مما ادى الى فقداننا كثير من زملائنا بين
شهيد ومصاب
وفق كثير من سيارات الاسعاف تجاوز عددها
105 سيارات كذلك نواجه مشاكل عدم توفر
الوقود البنيه التحتيه دمرت تدميرا شاملا
مما يؤثر على سيارات الاسعاف
وتحركها السعه السريريه لمستشفيات وزاره
الصحه تكاد ان تكون مفقوده وهذا يسبب لنا
مشاكل عند نقل الحالات الى
المستشفيات كنا بنتعامل مع حاله في
الاسعاف ورام ما تفاجانا الا باستهداف
استهداف كبير دخلت شظيه كبيره دخلت في قلب
زميل هو قاعد بيعف الحاله داخل الاعاب في
بدايه الحرب كنا ماشيين في الخط الساحلي
وجايين عند نقطه الساحل تم استهدافنا بشكل
مباشر لساره الاسعاف تم استهداف سياره
الاسعاف برصاص وقفت سياره الاسعاف بعد هيك
بلشوا يضربوا علي قذايف لحتى الان السياره
موجوده على نقطه الساحل يعني نقول
يستهدفوا طقط لا يستهدفنا بشكل مباشر يعني
سياره اسعاف كانت ماشيه وتم استهدافها
بشكل مباشر من البوارج ومن القناصه طبعا
احنا جاهزين لاي عمل لانه هذا عمل انساني
واحنا مستعدين له في اي وقت يعني رغم انه
قصفنا في سياره اسعاف ووقعنا وقعدنا فتره
ونحنا في اصابتنا الا انه بعد ما تعافينا
الحمد رجعنا تستمر وحده الاسعاف والطوارئ
في عملها داخل مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع على
الرغم من المخاطر الكبيره وفقدان هذه
الوحده 105 سياره اسعاف في الاستهداف
الاسرائيلي المتواصل على هذه المدينه
اسماعيل الغول قناه الجزيره مدينه غزه